was she treated unfairly by the media
and the press and the way she was
portrayed i think she was simply because
when you're talking about addiction it's
a disease
singer kelly price was a close friend of
whitney's just two nights before she
died in that bathtub at the beverly
hilton hotel whitney joined kelly on
stage for what would be her final
performance
[Applause]
what was whitney really like
she was a woman with a big heart
she loved people i think a lot of times
people would prefer to hear the wild and
the crazy because in their mind it's
it's buzz worthy it's newsworthy it's
the thing that will and in this day it's
called clickbait
but to know the whitney that i know to
know the whitney that i knew is to truly
know that you were blessed to know an
amazing human being before you ever got
to the voice
[Music]
dionne warwick was whitney's cousin and
she also wants the world to remember
whitney for her talent and grace what is
it that made her so special her talent
was is basically preordained a voice
like none other
which is the best part about it she was
always who she was and i decided
when did you know that she had the right
stuff to follow in your footsteps she
honed her craft
and i preached that chair
you know this is not a game
dion is like my second mother
in a lot of ways
but she's very proud and she's very
thrilled and she's very excited to see
what's happening with my career she was
around me so much
just like the little girl i never had
okay
and she was
she's a little devil she really was
she got everybody in trouble
she was very special baby she really was
[Applause]
god gave me something really great and
he doesn't give it to everybody we first
met whitney when she was just 20 years
old and in an la studio recording a duet
with jermaine jackson
my mom took me in the studio and
i've been working professionally since i
was 12 years old
just two years later we spent the day
with whitney and her parents as she got
ready for her very first grammy awards i
wouldn't want to have anybody else here
but my mom and dad and my family my
friends and it's just good to have them
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
of course one of whitney's most iconic
performances was at the 1991 super bowl
when i looked out there in the audience
amongst all those 85 000 people i could
see the intensity and the emotional
level that everyone was on and
as i began to sing it
i kind of blocked everything out
[Music]
i became a true american you know i i
felt proud to be an american
[Music]
a movie career six grammy awards wife to
bobby brown and mother to her beloved
daughter bobby christina whitney's life
was a series of triumphs and tragedies
in her short 48 years on this earth when
you say her name
speak well of her because she's not the
sum total of her weaknesses or her
mistakes if you got a chance to know her
heart
that was something special
[Applause]
[Music]